[Music]
Thank You Bethany you do this what just
happened
it's like you're afraid if I don't do
everything perfectly you're gonna lose
me okay I'm afraid even if you do
everything perfectly under what's your
name sandy good name one yeah
[Music]
oh shoot
so
[Applause]
hey don't you think
[Music]
you
hey youtubers surprise cloak-and-dagger
TV show just drop the trailer so let's
break this down so I'm just going to go
ahead and do a Marvel giveaway just
because it's cool that they drop this
it's kind of unexpected so all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video it's for one of
the spider-man action figures in the
interesting coincidence here is the
cloak-and-dagger debuted in a spider-man
comic book way back so all explains the
MCU connections and Easter eggs in this
too but also like the spider-man Home
Coming series these are younger versions
of the characters so you have young
Peter Parker in the MCU you have young
cloak-and-dagger in the MCU and just to
be clear this is a TV series on the
freeform Network which used to be called
ABC Family and it's not debuting until
2018 that could be spring that could be
fall they have not said so this is all
from the pilot episode they're doing
their powers much earlier I'll explain
their comic book origins because it's a
little bit different so what happened is
they both wound up being runaways
Tyrone Johnson cloak ran away when he
was about 17 years old after he was
unable to stop his friend from being
shot by police because of a speech
impediment Tandi Bowen dagger ran away
from her supermodel mother who was too
caught up in her celebrity lifestyle and
was a really shitty mom so she ran away
from home and wound up on the street
Tyrone wound up on the street they ran
into each other he considered robbing
her but then they hit it off they had
dinner and they became friends so
because she was kind of innocent he
tried to protect her as they tried to
live on the streets for a while
eventually they got an offer to earn
some money by being test subjects in a
science experiment the experiment is
what gave them their powers so because
you see the Roxon sign in this that's
one of the MCU easter eggs from agent
carter what that might mean is because
you see this offshore oil rig going down
and then her car going off in tyrone
jumping in to save her there might be
some sort of toxic chemicals Stanley
type of origin story whereby Roxon
poison or some crazy rocks an accident
gives them their powers because either
they get their powers here or they're
born with them that could be another
change from the comics just remains to
be seen we'll get that information
eventually but Roxon is sort of like a
catch-all big bad corporation for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe they've been
using it mostly with the TV shows it was
a big thing on agent Carter it was a big
thing on agents of shield so they're
like this giant
natural resources company that just
completely destroys the earth trying to
earn every bit of money that they can so
the other big easter egg that i haven't
seen anybody talking about and it's way
bigger
is that cloaks power enables him to
channel the dark force dimension so the
dark force dimension was something they
did on the agent carter TV show it was
basically the semi intelligent form of
energy that just caused this great
hunger in a character called madame
masque Whitney Frost so the accident
that gives cloak his powers just
basically turns him into a conduit for
the dark force so he's able to use it to
teleport that's what you see happen
later in the trailer when he just wakes
up on the rooftop ever it seems like
he's getting ready to get shot by this
police officer who's another big
character on the series but I don't know
if he's going to be someone from the
comics he can also create a field of
darkness that leeches people's life
force so he has this constant hunger the
dagger with her light based ability is
able to help quench so like over in the
DC Universe it's kind of like killer
frost and firestorm going out with each
other their powers kind of cancel each
other out so it's kind of the same thing
with cloak and dagger
so like when normal people actually come
into cloaks field of darkness they start
to lose their life force but if they're
traveling with dagger she can also
project a light field that will protect
them so that's one of the really big
reasons and explanations for why they
always come together yes they're in love
yes they're a couple but she is the only
person who can actually get close to him
without losing their life force so what
it looks like is happening in this is
because they're really young they're
still figuring their powers out like she
doesn't seem like she completely
understand what's going on when she
shanks this dude with this light dagger
when he's getting all pervy on her so
the only characters that they've
confirmed for the series are most of the
ones that appear in this trailer so you
have cloak and dagger you have their
parents and then you have a couple other
antagonistic characters revolving around
them there's a character called Liam no
last name who's supposed to be daggers
boyfriend and they say criminal partner
so you kind of see this weird thing
going on in the trailer where it looks
like daggers kissing other men it looks
like they're trying to scam money out of
really rich people so there's a little
explaining to go on with that so like
when you see someone pull out that wad
of $100 bills that's all part of her
storyline not cloaks storyline they
don't bump into
each other till later in the trailer
we're just sort of a casual meeting
while they're both on the run like you
see her holed up here in this abandoned
church it looks like at some point in
the episode she leaves home she runs
away like she does in the comics then
they run into each other and you see him
running through a graveyard here so the
big villain that's chasing them is
either somebody that we haven't seen in
the trailer or it's this cop that looks
like he's getting ready to kill cloak
earlier in the trailer because he's
called Conners and they just call him an
intimidating detective with a secret so
I don't know if he's a comic book
character either but there's not a lot
of information in this trailer it's just
meant to show you what their powers can
do how they come together and kind of
the drama that's going on in their own
lives so they're kind of like two down
and out on their luck teens who hit the
streets bump into each other start
helping out become friends and then
eventually become a couple but they have
these crazy powers and if you didn't
know there's another Marvel TV show on
the same network called new warrior so
you're probably familiar with them from
the comics but that series is completely
different it's going to be a comedy and
Squirrel Girl will be one of the main
characters so there might be crossover
between cloak-and-dagger and New
Warriors but the tone of both of those
shows seem dramatically different this
does seem like it's happening in New
York so it seems like it has a lot of
parody with daredevil with a Netflix
series just way darker and grittier New
Warriors as the comedy sounds like it's
going to be very different but because
they're on the same network and they're
both Marvel shows that means they could
cross over so let me know what you guys
think about this I honestly was not a
huge fan of cloak and dagger in the
comics but there was this funny time
during infinity war where cloak tried to
cloak Santos and leach his life force
did not go well for him
Santos was way too powerful for that
they'll probably bring it to Comic Con
release another trailer announced more
about the series I'm expecting to be
about 13 episodes I don't think it'll be
longer than that because freeform
doesn't really do like 24 episode
seasons like a lot of other networks but
think of it more is sort of like the
daredevil Netflix version of a more
younger version of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
the way that spider-man is a younger
spin on that side of the MCU so leave
all your questions in the comments below
I'll probably talk more about the New
Warriors TV show there's the runaways TV
show too but that's on Hulu so it's a
different network so there are a lot of
younger more
powerful characters that are hitting TV
series really soon but what's gonna
happen next is I was originally going to
do thor ragnarok and black panther
footage so i'll do that as soon as
possible
it might post later tonight if not it'll
just post early tomorrow morning so all
kinds of crazy Marvel stuff happening
this week it's going to be awesome while
you wait for that to post click here to
learn all about spider-man in the fourth
Avengers film in the Captain Marvel
preview Marvel release and click here
for that Superman prequel TV trailer for
Krypton thank you so much for watching
let's high five I'll see you guys in the
next video